hello there reject nation we are going
to watch what episode it's season three
episode 14. i love that you always
specified this season yeah man there's a
lot of brooklyn episodes up now it's
important these people know what they're
clicking on it's right it's time for
karen peralta
what are you talking about that's the
title of the episode oh
uh spoilers and it was directed by it
was
john john
he's gonna turn into a karen this leave
a like
also uh full-length watch alongside sync
up with the time code for benign or over
at our patreon page appreciate all who
become super sexy rejects by checking
all that we got to offer over there and
uh the prepper team thank you for
helping setting down these highlights
all right guys let's have a good laugh
if it's funny
gather round glorious turd monsters and
feast your eyes on what i hold in this
hand the future of movement a hoverboard
is walking really so hard for you oh
ames walking's a nightmare yeah amy
golly okay a little harder to control
than i thought
i've never ridden one but there we go
i think i'm getting the hang of it no
i'm not
oh jeeps
i'm all
right god the birthday boy
charles probably shouldn't have done
that in a police station what's this
case it's research on your mom since
we're finally meeting she's gonna love
you you're both strong accomplished
women that have seen me naked
oh my
what is my mother's favorite drink red
wine over ice just like diane keaton
favorite topics of conversation jimmy
carter is underrated how beautiful some
front doors are what's jane seymour up
to and how cool is it that the ladies
across the street are lesbians great
nice work
are you excited for our escape the room
team building exercise i told you sir it
would be far more effective for the
squad to go to vegas and you give us
each five thousand dollars yeah i see no
value of that there's no rosa no terry
that leaves me with
ah
yes do it before we do anything else
are your body cams turned on why are you
so obsessed with these things it's like
your stupid babies all over again my
babies are not stupid cagney can write a
lowercase l it's just a line right
hi birthday boy hi
mom is something on fire yeah mom
seriously the fire it's fine things
don't burn down like they used to i'm
just gonna put it out
you know it's good enough for diane
keaton it's good enough for me is that
katie sickle yeah
where is jane seymour now anyway she
makes jewelry and it's beautiful i just
bought two brooches for the lesbians
across the street mom i keep telling you
if you don't rain it in a little bit
you're gonna scare them off well that's
what you said about carla and now i have
a friend with one arm
birthday surprise you got me the 86 mets
be warned a lot of them turned out to be
drug addicts so this could be a bummer
you ready
oh oh god oh no dad
what are you doing here i wanted to
surprise you yeah well i am surprised
actually jake your father and i are uh
seeing each other again
oh
that's so interesting
we are in your childhood bedroom and i
do have one question
did you have a nose ring in high school
yes until i got infected and i almost
went blind don't tell anyone like andrew
miller yeah bring that look back what is
going on here why is my dad dating my
mom what does he want money but she's a
public school art teacher that doesn't
make any sense
maybe that son of a [ __ ] wants his
picture drawn
[Laughter]
you don't know her like i do she's too
trusting for her own good she's fallen
for more nigerian scams than scully
she's fallen for 20 nigerian scams 20.
that's insane no she's falling for two
skully's fallen for 20.
this is fine it's just the same that
it's always been i have to protect her
i'm gonna go down there and i'm going to
express my concerns to her in a calm
rational manner what are you doing mom
he's evil
oh it's not turning back on do you think
sarge is going to be mad that i spilled
the fur on the cam he definitely wants
to say full like that when you tell him
i'm not going to mispronounce it not
while you're rolling go get yourself
cleaned up
just put it in some rice charles don't
know why i didn't go undercover as
someone wearing a scarf terry hates
windchill here's our guy got him
crap i think he made me
he's headed toward the restaurant you
follow i'll cover the back alley
shoot him
discharge her weapon indiscriminately
rosa
charles
you're completely naked
where is everyone gina perhaps that's
tonight's first puzzle
i forgot to send the invitations but i
was able to rally the best and brightest
of those available
oh dear god sorry relate
turns out the front door is a push not a
pull
i love that joke
got your favorite cake blue i'm not
hungry
it's a figure of speech obviously i'll
have some
i know that you're angry but when i was
here last year you really showed me what
a selfish jerk i was you're the reason
that all of this is happening oh you
dick
no i just wanted you to text me a dumb
dad joke every six months i can do that
just give me your number you didn't save
my number now jake
[Laughter]
blow out your candles okay great great
idea mom i'll blow out
my birthday candles
i wish that you would leave
okay we have maps a pantry beds a desk
where should we begin get under those
mattresses you didn't come back down i
had to talk to your parents for like an
hour and i ran out of stuff from the
binder and then i did something really
weird
the itsy bitsy spider went up the water
spout
oh my
substitute teacher vibes
but think about how i feel my stupid
parents are borking each other
who doesn't even know that he cheated on
her with her best friend sheila boden oh
my god they were in our car in the
garage having sex i'm gonna tell my dad
if he doesn't do the decent thing and
leave my mom again
i'm dropping the sheila bomb i know this
is a really big deal but i have to ask
did you wear this hat in high school amy
you have to tell my mom that you need to
speak with her in private about what i
barely know her uh
tell her you're plugged up and you need
a laxative what
i'll drop the bomb during sharing so
i'll just tell him i know about sheila
with my body
uh
oh geez
oh i i didn't no no no it's fine it's
not i'm not um right what would you be
yeah well it's not like i'm always uh
naked yeah
it's not like i'm dying to tell anyone i
saw your benny and the jets
i just talked to our purpose attorney
he's claiming the drugs you seize in the
bathroom weren't his but lucky for us
you were wearing body cams yeah but the
thing about cameras is that they don't
really tell the full objective truth
people often seem naked
boyle is fully nude in the footage why
it doesn't matter how much humping i do
he's still not getting it and this is
happening hey karen can i talk to you
for a second in private i'm a little
plugged up
oh well
it was you and sheila baden humping it
up in the back of our car you think i'm
way more sexually active than i am i've
only had sex with like 400 women what
god is that a lot i mean uh all my
friends are pilots i'm on that low end
of average
if i'm correct this should contain key
number one yay open the door no we need
to find four keys and it took half our
time just to find this one because
you're all useless how does one man chew
so loud with just one mouth sorry
you gotta turn it like four times just
to change the damn channel four times
try turning it to
22 18 81 17. the coordinates for the bay
of pigs
nice job you broke the tv no i found
another key you dolt so one was in a
night the basketball teams were the
mustangs and stallion you're damn right
it will cause we're smart ass team
where's your father he left very
suddenly what did he do jake nothing you
know just like super awful life-changing
things no follow-up questions is it
worse than the time he cheated on me
with sheila baden you knew about that i
knew about that
[Music]
no
no
i also knew about wendy and bonnie
bonnie who wears a wig she left it in
our bathroom that's how i found out and
also remember your turtle graham
crackers dad had sex with my turtle no
no no no but he he stepped on it getting
out of bed but
how did i not know any of this stuff
well because you were a kid kids don't
actually know a lot about their parents
jake i've dated a lot of men in the last
20 years you have a lot okay you don't
have to put so much mustard on it
i was just trying to protect you but i
clearly made everything worse you have
been protecting me since you were a kid
sometimes i think
you got so good at it you decided to
become a cop and protect everyone that
doesn't line up
you know i'm probably remembering a lot
more nakedness than there actually was
no you're not oh look no one's gonna see
it on that little tv
great news we were able to snag the new
flat screen oh yeah
look at that and tell me what you see a
naked fool no between the thighs and
under the testicles that's a bag of
cocaine a bag of cocaine that's gonna
get us a conviction and prove the value
of body cams now let's zoom in
over zoomed over suit
look i talked to mom and i just want her
to be happy so can we go back to my
birthday party now if you screw this up
and hurt her in any anyway i will throw
you in jail for the rest of your life
and i can do that now dad so do not test
me i still like the hug even though you
used it to threaten me
[Laughter]
i kind of liked threatening you
so we found key number three thanks to
scully i was gonna eat those peaches
anyway team
what in this room is speaking to you
right now um i'm intrigued by the phone
it looks like it would be fun to call a
friend on it and talk about a third
friend behind their back
interesting they had an hour and 27
minutes it's most cold i know morse code
my dad was a prisoner war in korea and i
could only talk to him
who cares just decode the message
geez it's a phone number
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
ready
one
oh
24.
congratulations we did it and we did it
together because we're a team should we
do it again next week sir no i would
hate that
by the way
amy was really nervous to meet you so
don't judge her too harshly for all the
weird singing oh no i'm dating my son of
a [ __ ] ex-husband who am i to judge i
think she's really great
i think you're really great too
she's very good at lip reading i
wouldn't say i'm very good
i'll let you guys talk i'll just close
my eyes
oh amy amy
you freak
freak of nature
bitsy freak
gross freak have you ever done escape
rooms i've done a couple escape rooms
did you do good i feel like you'd be
great at excuse me okay i did okay
john's version of okay means above
average
i mean if you're implying like did i
just like swoop in and solve everything
for everybody no but uh you know i mean
i'm good at uh you know to get rolling
my sleeves up and getting inquisitive
i'm good at
uh i'm not a good person to do this game
i feel like you're gonna be playing
simple with you guys i'm not the not the
guy you want to do so you would be the
perfect guy you would be you would need
we would need to agree that you would be
the manager of the escape experience
because then you could maximize the
amount of time we have and probably
point everyone in the right direction to
solve it most effectively
i've done them i'm not good no
either
i'm either just bullshitting my way into
seeming like i'm contributing to the
team when i'm not figuring out anything
okay or um i'm trying to be funny and
i'm just annoying everyone
also can see when they're trying to
take this seriously and get the job done
yeah yeah i'm like
i
i'm not a good person to do escape rooms
with very frustrating
we gotta go now we gotta put this to the
test
i i just don't i can't i have a hard
time understanding
let's just get all the real rejects
together i think i contributed one thing
one time
and i was like
remember when i figured out that one
glue out of the two hours we were in
there that's better than notice some
people in here haven't figured out a
single clue at all so yeah um let's go
do one sometime let's do it let's see
how we've changed that was funny that
was really funny
i just love that ending note with the
whole no i would hate that
i know
such a true feeling
it was like oh you did it but i would
never want no matter what we achieved
today
let's leave it here
that happens a little more often than um
normal i think with uh not normal but
but more than expected with people
getting back with
their ex lovers from many years ago
and um the benefits of maturity that
insane level of
forgiveness she has i can't imagine
there's multiple cheatings and stuff
she's a catch katy skull
for like an 80 year old woman
you know what i mean that's right man
for an octogenarian
yeah she is really really uh you know
keeping up with the young bucks
uh yeah it's it's kind of it's funny how
this they get these like
reputable actors
or actresses even
they don't really give them
funny stuff to do i know they give them
like actual performance
like charactery thing like i thought
there were a lot of very sweet scenes
between uh jake and karen in this
episode but yeah it was sort of like i
would ex he was yeah you associate like
oh she's gonna do like a big character
but no
yeah they set her up to be like
wildly whimsical kooky yeah she's gonna
be like kooky hippie art lady like
total cartoon trying to be progressive
yeah lady you're just like no i guess
she's just a
holistic arty person who gets it you
know who who manages seems to manage her
life pretty well aside from love
i grew up on merrywood children i know a
lot of people know her from more modern
work because she and sons i haven't seen
sons of anarchy but i believe she's in
sons of anarchy yeah
and um or people think like the second
you hear her voice you're like leela
you know futurama yeah yeah exactly um
where i i don't uh
i don't really associate her with being
because i've never watched sons of
anarchy please don't request that we
watch
i know
funny enough that's usually my go-to
example for like there's too much tv and
i have to accept that there's some great
tv i'll never see and sons of anarchy
probably one of those shows well
my weird dream of winning the lottery is
just me
hey the first thing i do is introduce
olivia
to the breaking bad universe oh my my
first dream
early
i would re-watch tv i've already seen
and then catch up on the stuff i've
really been saving travel
so
start up some kind of passion project no
no no
uh
i got i got i got a hundred episodes to
catch up with keep my bills the same and
watch television that's what
uh yeah and then yeah ketchup on shows
like the wire and
there's a list in a lot of shows
why you react to this yeah
the wire and that's when i'll watch
dexter's when i win the lottery oh man
yeah it's a great show um
so yeah but anyway um
enough about the wire but uh bradley
whitford he is uh
he's like one of those hitters like
there's a certain category of actors out
there
bradley woodford richard jenkins
that's it
mark rylance a little bit maybe he's not
gonna he's an oscar winner though isn't
he
he's a little more perspective he's got
clout now yeah yeah
someone's getting arrested outside
moved to a safe neighborhood that's
right this safe means there's just more
police activity yeah they're actually
stopping the crime yeah they're showing
up and being like hey
what are you doing
um
yeah uh but but bradley wifford is like
he's got that
way where he doesn't ever seem like he's
like he he does comedy so well
without
ever performing it like he's in a comedy
mm-hmm
like he knows how to just be sincere
like like andy samberg in most of the
cast brooklyn like they're embodying a
comedy show yeah but actors like bradley
woodford
um
can just play like oh you're
straightforward here you're just you're
not doing this for laughs but then you
just have like an unexpected funny line
yeah and he plays it like that line
about the 400 women
i'm on the low end of average
[Laughter]
yeah it's like it's so you don't see it
coming simply because of house and
series being yeah sets you up to expect
yeah it plays your expectations by using
authenticity
um against you then we also uncover more
about
um you know jake and his
his uh
need to
his
protect
to insert himself into situations and
ensure
they are safe to his standards
or just to his standards
makes sense i mean i like kind of the
fleshing out of his character because
he's one of those characters that's
really believable just having female
friendships
and you could see that with someone
who's that bonded with his mom yeah
totally totes and uh
got a nice rapport like i like their see
like as much as it's not that kind of
show i was like those are some nice
little scenes back and forth between the
two of them like i like their
relationship and i think she's a really
good contrast from bradley whitford as i
mean even though in his more
uh you know put catherine keener in that
same category sure yeah
but she'll show up i mean she i feel
like she and uh and bradley whiffer can
both do that thing where they'll show up
and like hear something more broad or
hear something more serious but you're
always kind of yeah
um or mary steen virgin mary steen
virgin another good call yeah definitely
um but yeah as it stands another solid
ass episode had a great time
no alcohol required scully and hitchcock
figured some [ __ ] out we we didn't get
to see charles's dick release the the
uncensored cut
i
released the uncensored brooklyn god
that'd be so embarrassing i know zoom
too far
so we got completely naked no
i just take the vest off
just to the camera it's all black
the editing on this show is so good
yeah
i think like phil lord and chris miller
setting the stage for how to make this
show really panned out well
because they're yeah they're coming
their comic timing is so like when it
comes to the editing a lot of these
jokes would not work if it wasn't for
like the solid editing yeah it's like
you so much of it is supposed to look
sort of like you're there so you're
supposed to kind of look past it but
yeah it's like it's the combination of
like the performances and the comedic
timing obviously but there's a lot yeah
of filmmaking based comedy
on display well like when he you know
i'm gonna go down there and talk to my
dad
and he'll talk to my mom about my dad
he's like why are you doing this he's
evil
rational talk
what is it uh
terry finds out that boyle was naked on
camera
why
and it's so yeah it's such a believable
and also just the way they captured that
is like the perfect punctuation like
it's such a it's it's a believable like
that that line delivery from terry's so
funny because
it's
it's like why did you it's not exactly
like
it's it's a perfectly layered delivery
of why because
you're like
obviously terry can see that that could
happen yes he knows boyle
he knows it's possible but it's just
like why did it happen
now
[Laughter]
and why were you not like
it's not like he's surprised
but
just yeah it's like dude not now yeah
yeah it's like a perfect delivery of why
yeah i was going whoa
yeah yeah like a perfect delivery yeah
why now and why completely naked
or like the because a lot of the times
with these comedy jokes it's also about
when you cut away for the joke to land
instead of letting the camera linger
on a line like sometimes the laugh is
made because they cut away mm-hmm like
quick-cut um
like when uh
hitchcock and scully walk through the
door i i kind of like
wait here i say that's called
you know why i do that because i'm
always like is it school you're solely
when he comes to the door and he's like
and they're out of breath
[Laughter]
it's like a perfect line
because they look exhausted so
immediately your mind just goes like
they must have like ran over here we're
running late yeah
something must have taken a while had
been a massive inconvenience here
they're struggling with this
yeah yeah and then you're forced to
imagine them going
what's wrong with the door
what do we do
as
one of the most memorable jokes i think
that's the room it's gonna stick with me
from those two that's an all-time
hitchcock and scully yeah and it's also
i want to know
of all like the the cold opens
and i don't mean this in a mean or like
even a complaining kind of way but this
was so i was wondering like how many of
these cold opens are the writers just
sitting around going what do we do
hey that guy just got a new hoverboard
let's just make something out of that
well i
i think like i don't know comedy can be
such a fascinating line to me
that comedy's so specific you know
like because
if if hitch if uh hitchcock ran through
the door saying
you know sorry we're late i tried
opening the door but it's supposed to be
it's supposed to be pushed not pulled
that's not funny
but to say like sorry we're late
apparently the door was pushed not
pulled but it's just like so much
funnier
yeah yeah it turns it into this like
outside circumstance this is like random
happening that intervened upon their
otherwise perfect plan
that's a that was just such a funny line
i thought yeah yeah like
i admired that that lines that the way
that was set up so much that was so
funny a hitchcock and scully all-time
moment right there
yeah yeah that was that was probably the
funniest thing i think they've ever had
i would agree i would agree with that
that was a brilliant line of comedy
anyway all right guys now that we've
taught you about how comedy works yes
now that we've explained these jokes
now you guys know now you guys know how
to be funny take the tools we've um
instilled you with today and make the
world laugh as you go about your your
life we made this funnier we made this
funnier by showing you why it's funny
yeah
so that's how we should do the reactions
we would pause and stop we haven't like
now here's what's going on here here's
what makes this mine funny let me
dissect this comedy for you guys
um all right guys well thank you for
being here and we'll catch y'all soon